if you've been following the trial and i
know you have because we have been
covering it pretty closely on this show
you'll know that the prosecution has
flopped every single step of the way
everything that we were told by the
media about kyle rittenhouse about
kenosha about the shooting basically
everything we were told was bs
all of the arguments that the
prosecution made fell flat all of the
evidence was on kyle rittenhouse's side
and the side of his self-defense claims
and none of the evidence was on the
prosecution side a lot of it came down
to footage from the night there were a
lot of cameras out there and apparently
law enforcement had
a drone going over and was able to view
what was going on and who shot when and
who turned when and who turned where
so
take a look
at the footage that the defense had the
kyle rittenhouse team had compared to
the footage that the prosecution
had
you can if you're if you're just
listening right now i will describe to
you the difference it's pretty pretty
clear
uh
the defense had very very blurry grainy
footage it looks like it was taken on a
flip phone from
i don't know 2002
the prosecution had crystal clear
high definition incredible footage where
you could make out every little detail
it's not even close
and you can just look at the size of the
files the defense had video that was 3.6
megabytes
the
prosecution had video that was 11.2
megabytes so
you're talking about three times the
quality for the prosecution as for
the defense so
so what happened
well when this was was brought up
the the prosecution made the segment
said no look all we did we just copied
the file we gave look we gave the
defense the same file and look if there
was a problem with the quality of the
footage you know the crucial evidence in
this case it's just because
the defense teams you know their cell
phones were wrong or their or their
computers were messed up but it's not
because we didn't do anything we're not
hiding evidence
it's something on your end you had the
exact same file now here's how the
defense proved that was complete bs
every other piece of evidence from the
state crime lab in this situation has
been provided to us via dropbox dropbox
provides an exact forensic copy of what
they have
the file title name in this situation
should have been exactly the same as the
one provided to the state if it was the
exact same copy
the file name was nowhere near similar
there's no way that what ada kraus is
saying is true because
the file name would not have changed if
my computer was compressing anything it
was a different file that we were
provided from what was provided to the
state
she's got these guys dead to rights
i never want to attribute to malice that
which is equally explained by stupidity
and the prosecution has demonstrated a
lot of stupidity in this case the
arguments they're making where they say
that if you if you arm yourself you lose
the right to self-defense of course
that's
preposterous
if arming yourself would would lose you
your right to self-defense then there
simply is no right to self-defense the
the prosecution lifting up an ar-15 in a
courtroom swinging it around the
courtroom finger on the trigger i mean
just pure stupidity so i'm not i'm not
denying that they could have been stupid
enough
not to realize what they did but this
required an intentional action you would
have had to go in there
you would have had to reduce the quality
of the video
and you would have had to change the
file name
so this can't be just a problem of copy
paste whoops it it read differently on a
different computer
the prosecution provided the defense
with a different file a file that was
much lower quality a file that put them
at a much
at a real disadvantage
for the crucial evidence in
the case and these guys are corrupt okay
it's as simple as that
they are corrupt they might also be
stupid they might also be ignorant they
might also be incompetent
but i'm seeing malice
i am seeing corruption here and i think
we all are i'm glad you like that clip
subscribe
please please that would be great ring
the bell you will get the notifications
if you really want to guarantee you get
the notifications and the whole
uncensored show head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts that's the place to get it type
in the michael knowles show leave a
five-star review if you wouldn't mind
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]